thank you for joining us I'm John
langler and we start with sports you
know it wasn't too long ago Las Vegas
was known for major boxing matches and
that was kind of it well times have
changed slightly today the NCAA
announced it's bringing the men's
basketball Final Four right to a legion
Stadium lvcva said this morning that it
won the bidding process to host the end
of March Madness here it'll be April
2028. so you have some time to save
money for the tickets Las Vegas is no
stranger to major college hoops of
course the UNLV title was back in 1990
there's other conference tournaments
that have been hosted here the last
several years but this is a big deal the
final four coming to Las Vegas the
addition of final four men's basketball
is the latest addition to a jam-packed
sports schedule here in Las Vegas there
are nine other college hoops
championships here before 2026 the
Pac-12 Conference big West for example
whack Allegiant stadium is hosting the
Super Bowl in 2024 and then there's the
Las Vegas Grand Prix scheduled for
November of 2023. in addition to the
knights and the Raiders and everything
else